in which other ways as you outline your
book is life getting better because I
think well I have I mean I have 50
charts in there yeah where everything is
getting better I think there's a kind of
cynicism about
um like if even if we look at extreme
poverty for example for example this is
actually a poll taken on Extreme poverty
and the people were asked
has poverty gotten better or worse and
the options are increased by 50
increased by 25 percent remain the same
decreased by 25 percent decreased by 50
if you're watching this or listening to
this try to to try to vote for yourself
seventy percent thought it had gotten
worse and then that's the general
impression
88 thought it had gotten worse or
remained the same
only one percent thought it decreased by
50 and that is the answer it actually
decreased by 50 so only one percent of
people got the right optimistic estimate
of how uh poverty is right and and this
is the reality and it's true of almost
everything you look at you don't want to
go back 100 years or 50 years things
were quite miserable then but we tend
not to
remember that so literacy rate
increasing over the past few centuries
across all the different nations
nearly to 100 across many of the nations
in the world it's gone way up average
years of education have gone way up life
expectancy is also increasing life
expectancy was
48 in 1900
and it's over 80 now and it's going to
continue to go up particularly as we get
into more advanced stages of simulated
biology
for life expectancy these Trends are the
same for at Birth age 1 Age 5 age 10 so
it's not just the infant mortality and I
have 50 more graphs in the book about
all kinds of things
uh even spread of democracy we try
to bring up some sort of controversial
issues it still has gone way up
well that one is uh it's gone way up but
that one is a bumpy road right exactly
and some somebody might represent
democracy and
and go backwards but
we basically had no democracies before
the creation of the United States which
was a little over two centuries ago
the scale of human history isn't that
long